assurer la protection des Canadiens en
bannissant des armes d'assaut c'était
l'engagement du gouvernement fédéral
l'automne dernier
ministre de la Sécurité publique parlait
à l'époque d'interdire 500 modèles
d'armes supplémentaires il fait marche
arrière et propose plutôt de créer une
définition des fusils à bannir ces
réformes visent à éliminer les armes
d'assaut de nos roues tout en respectant
les propriétaires dans ma feuille les
armes à feu qui ne sont pas des armes de
poing tirent des munitions à percussions
centrale de manière semi-automatique et
qui ont été conçus avec un chargeur
détachable d'une capacité de six
cartouches ou plus serait prohibé
des amendements qui lorsqu’il
deviendront loi s'appliqueront
uniquement aux nouvelles armes à feu et
non pas à celles déjà en circulation
cette définition qui s'appliquera
prospectivement sera inséré dans le code
pénal le gouvernement minoritaire semble
avoir adopté la voie du compromis
les parties d'opposition considéraient
la proposition originale d'Ottawa comme
une atteinte au droit des chasseurs des
agriculteurs et des autochtones
depuis le début nous on croit que
dresser une liste comme le gouvernement
semblable à l'intention de le faire au
début c'est problématique parce que
c'est trop limitatif les nouveaux
amendements permettront aussi de saisir
contre les armes fantômes armes
fabriquées à l'aide d'imprimantes 3D de
fermer ces échappe à toi là pour nous
primordial pour mettre en place vraiment
un projet de loi qui a du sens qui a
quoi lièvre prévient qu'on ne peut pas
faire confiance à Justin Trudeau
lorsqu'il affirme ne pas vouloir s'en
prendre au chasseur
bonsoir mais c'est une claque au visage
selon des survivants de tuerie je suis
extrêmement colère extrêmement déçu et
je me sens trahie trahi encore une fois
parce que c'est pas la première fois
qu'on dit à Monsieur Trudeau et à son
équipe que c'est pas ça qui a promis
qu'on a été le dindon de la force de
partir c'est-à-dire on n'a pas mis ce
projet à la hauteur d'une nation c'est
parti négocier entre eux pour avoir
donne-moi le beurre je te donne du pain
la grande absente sur les armes à bannir
la carabine SKS utilisez lors de
nombreuses stérils au pays au cours des
dernières années imaginez une tuerie
avec un SKS dans un mois dans trois dans
un an même c'est incroyable mais c'est
possible
imaginez pour tapis que dans un mois
dans un an comment ils vont se regarder
dans le miroir en tout cas moi je vais
l'avoir dit que ça avait pas de bon sens
une autre liste qui compte 2000 armes
interdites demeure mais comme cette
liste n'est pas inscrite dans la loi un
gouvernement ultérieur pourrait la
modifier ici Valérie Michael
Radio-Canada
Ottawa